I wish I had something more positive to
start with today but I unfortunately
need to talk to you about an existential
threat not only to the David Pakman show
but to other programs that you may
listen to or watch we are in the midst
of what is called what is being called a
YouTube advertiser boycott and to cut to
the chase it's resulted in a ninety-five
percent reduction in our youtube revenue
over the last four days as well as that
similar level of decline in revenue for
many of our other friends who have
programs many shows that that you know
and probably watch what started this is
that there were a couple of articles
written showing ads from major
advertisers on videos with blatantly
hateful racist xenophobic or violent
titles or content this includes videos
with titles like the n-word on tiny
channels with fewer than a thousand
subscribers this includes some slightly
larger channels and this panicked
advertisers the article said hey brands
YouTube can't seem to control whether
your ads show up on videos promoting
hateful and horrible stuff advertisers
started immediately either pulling their
advertising from YouTube or threatening
to pull them their money from YouTube
and what this has led to is a near total
and complete shutdown of all advertising
on many many channels we are affected
Kyle kolinsky secular talk is affected
our friends at the Young Turks are
affected not everybody is affected there
seems to be a slightly sporadic nature
to it but case in point youtube revenue
for us has fallen off the cliff if
you're someone who had been waiting or
hoping for the demise of the david
pakman show this is a step in that
direction i will be absolutely clear and
upfront with you what these people exist
right like this person who called in
when news of this broke you know i hope
to cancel you out you what that smirk
off your face
case you don't know anything but it
seems president chump you have no
courtesy do you your show sucks hmm so
many people are happy about this I'm
getting emails from people think David
I've been waiting for this this is going
to destroy your show now why is this so
important as you know membership is the
the number one funding source for us but
youtube is very close about 48 to 52
percent of our revenue comes from
membership on any given month around
forty percent of it comes from YouTube
meaning YouTube revenue represents close
to half of our revenue this is the
revenue that goes to fund the studio and
staff salaries and the distribution of
the program to two hundred radio and TV
stations that have no money to buy the
show right we produce the show and give
it to those stations as a public service
because we need alternative viewpoints
out there I there's no reason for me to
neither sugarcoat nor exaggerate how big
this is forty percent of our revenue if
it's not made up for in one way or
another will destroy the david pakman
show now i believe that those who
understand the importance of what we do
especially now are stronger than the
trolls and the hatreds and the haters
that's my belief at least one person has
already called in saying they're
doubling their membership take a listen
to this hey gave the gone Marty from
Ontario here just let you know I'm
doubling my payment from five bucks a
month to ten bucks a month just thinking
is like such a video with the YouTube
crackdown on advertising and really
there is no show like yours are second
to none better than tu on TV you've had
as in Calculon ski although those guys
are pretty good it'd be a shame after
your show wasn't able to continue so
yeah that's taken care of and to
everybody else you guys need to get up
and support this show forget about
YouTube advertising let's make sure this
show can stay a intact okay have you
guys but this ad boycott is hurting not
only tiny little channels that are just
out there spouting anti-semitism and
racism and misogyny and all sorts of
stuff it's hurting channels like ours
that are out there exposing that it
is deemed quote controversial the new
YouTube system currently as of right now
can't distinguish between someone being
anti-semitic and someone denouncing
anti-semitism and that's why Pat this is
so sick because at its core these
advertisers were making a move that was
against hateful content and as a result
they're hurting producers like us that
are out there exposing the hateful
content because the system YouTube has
just has shut the whole thing down it
really is a shame because it's cracking
down on what made you too great in the
first place yep you can have all these
diverse perhaps controversial ideas out
there and you can sign these niche
channels and you know have these big
discussions on politics and religion and
the problem I think is people may start
self-censoring because even though they
may not take videos down people I think
well if my videos aren't going to get
monetized if I talk about this
controversial topic they may just ignore
the issue altogether and this is a boon
for corporate media and your likes on
pat right I mean you're it's been on
this entire time it is on a good good
good sometimes I have a hard time
hearing packet as we sit not right next
to each other this is a boon for
corporate media okay because if GM pulls
10 million bucks out of youtube which
would go partially to establishment
media and partially towards small
channels right they're still going to
put that money into advertising but
they'll call up MSNBC they'll call up
CNN so this is a move away from
independent media and towards corporate
media this is not a joke this is a
practical importance as much as it is
about ideological and political
importance because it will silence
voices and it will prop up corporate
media we we are we are committed to
replacing this revenue okay I don't know
what will eventually happen with YouTube
I'm hoping some portion of the of the
revenue will recover I don't know what
will happen a segment producer Noah
wrote to me saying hey David listen
we've got to keep things going if you
need me to work for less money I'll work
for less money and I said you know the
good thing right now Noah is we don't
have to do that right now right we over
the next six to 12 months we've got to
replace this revenue but we're okay
right now but that's the level of
commitment Pat that we have because this
is a move to silence alternative
voices effectively that's what it will
do and it's entirely possible that by
next week this problem could be fixed
that there's some new ad system set up
but we can't expect to get back to the
hundred percent amount of revenue that
we were taking in before right that's
kind of the best scenario the worst case
scenario is that this continues so what
we need to do right now is we need to
push membership okay when you watch a
video on youtube and an ad plays before
it we get a fraction of a penny for that
it's like two tens like a one-fifth of a
penny is what we get if you just go to
david pakman.com slash membership and
sign up for six bucks a month you were
essentially paying three cents per
YouTube clip is the way to think about
it or you're paying a couple bucks for
an entire one hour podcast with multiple
staff and all of the resources of our
studio we estimate that about one
percent one percent of our audience are
paid members at david pakman.com slash
membership if we can get to 2% we
immediately replace all lost revenue if
we could get two three or four percent
of our audience joining the membership
program we no longer care about the loss
youtube revenue because we have replaced
it and more so six dollars a month or 60
for the year is what membership costs if
that's too high and i get that that's a
lot of money for many people we have a
coupon code it's forty percent off okay
the coupon code is all one word all
lower case i voted 17 this is the time
everything I've said in the past about
membership Pat and we joke around
membership you know I don't often
mention it of course I do and make
different jokes this is the moment we've
got to replace this revenue and people
already are signing up I don't care at
what level you sign up we have just
suffered a forty percent reduction to
our revenue it's just math we've got to
make it up and without any warning to
that's perhaps the worst part of this so
now is the time to contribute if
possible we will tell you what goes on
i'll probably do a live stream later
with updates about what's going on but
in the meantime please please please
david pakman.com slash membership use
the coupon code if you want i voted 17